about two years ago a guy named pete
smits
wanted a custom feature from a blheli32
esc
and here's the problem blheli32 is
closed source
only the blheli32 developers can modify
the firmware on a blh-32e
bls blheli s is open source and lots of
people are working on modifying and
improving it
open source is awesome but the problem
is blheli sescs
are slower they have less processing
power they have less memory
and they just can't do as much as bla-32
esc's
so pete schmitz gave up and went on
about his life
no pete spitz sat down
and started working on a whole new
firmware for
blheli32escs and as you'll see in this
interview which that's what today's
video is an interview with pete
he thought oh i'm gonna just write an
esc firmware how hard could it be
and two years later here he is and it's
basically done
and in fact right now if you want to use
this firmware
flashing it onto the esc is a little bit
cumbersome
but diatone is working on esc's with
this firmware already
on them and i'll make a video about that
when they finally come out but today
i would like you to sit down with me and
meet pete smits the guy who just one day
wrote his own firmware for esc's from
scratch
because he thought it would be cool
and i'm really excited i'm excited i
don't know if you can tell
i'm excited about this because some of
the work that's going on
in this am 32 esc
open source it's they're making esc's do
things
really cool that like people don't think
why would you do that
but you can now that there's an open
anyway on with the interview
well i guess i guess i would ask like
what is so what motivated you
tell me the story of how you came to do
this like
was it just like a passion project did
you see a deficit
that you wanted to solve uh well i've
been doing hardware for
longer than i've ever written a line of
code
i've been and now i was making hardware
for simon k
firmware back in the day and then when
bl heli became a thing
i was making hardware with uh and coming
up with uh
anything that pops into my head if
there's a new part on the market i've
got a truck
and if it's a new mosfet that comes out
from a manufacturer or a new driver
or a new mcu i gotta try so it's uh
and then i actually started making some
32-bit
controllers on this uh mcu called the
st spin 32 which is a little all-in-one
microcontroller and gate driver and it
was pretty cool
and i i'd asked uh
stefan um if he would license
a version of blheli32
to because i want to just buy it and i
didn't want it i knew it was closed
source and said hey can you
can you license i can register the
uid of the chip and you know we could
just license a copy
and he wouldn't do that so and i've
already made the boards at that point in
time so i thought okay well that's kind
of
yeah i didn't really want to start
writing firmware at that point in time
but
unless i do that so you had weights
back up back up you had a custom
hardware that you'd build a custom esc
because you were interested in trying
out these different whatever
fet drivers and processors and so forth
to see if you could get better
performance or just out of curiosity
but you needed software to run on it
yeah blheli32 being closed source
you couldn't just flash it and he
wouldn't license it to you so you were
just like
okay i guess i'll just write my own well
and there was a bit of time in between
where
i thought i was going to be able to
which i probably wouldn't even started a
hardware project but
um way back in the bles days i said
when he announced blhelia32 i said well
can i buy a license for a hobbyist when
you've got
the lle 32 out and he said i'm sure we
can arrange something
but that's great well i made some
hardware and then when it came to it
it was just and he was very polite about
it and i under you know he said it's
only for manufacturers and i'm only
going to deal with
with harbor manufacturers and not
individual hobbyists
well i'm sure that was disappointing i
do
i do i don't want to like sound like
we're piling on stefan who does a ton of
work
like i mean i wanted to use his firmware
in the first place i think bl helly is
great
and i i i probably wouldn't have started
this project
if i had known how much work it was
going to be you know that was
that was two years ago now and i thought
how hard would it be to get a motor to
spin you know it's just
like you just need to make something go
in a circle right like
but you know it was it was a lot of work
involved
famous last words now let me ask you why
why
why didn't you use blheli s because
blheli s is open source
um i'm sure there's a good answer for
that
yeah well i mean the the big thing was i
mean some of the
bl helis was getting to the end of its
days when it comes to
new capabilities and well i was trying
to make a
sensorless speed controller at the time
that used spi
as an input and that just wasn't
something that was even unless i
asked stefan to code me some spi
input for bl helles which wouldn't be on
his radar i mean i
i couldn't understand um assembly
um no i see right because bl hilly s was
written completely in
this crazy obscure assembly code that
like
five people in the world i'm
exaggerating but not by much
no so even though it was it was funny to
me because although it was open source
almost no one else in the world could
actually work with it
because it was successful yeah yeah i
know i mean it's and i i could actually
written an arduino-based
sort of esc program before so i wasn't
completely new to it but
i couldn't understand a single bit i
just got so lost every single time i
stared at bl
ali i couldn't understand it at all and
yeah and i still can't to this day
now now why did you want an spi based
interface for your esc
what's the advantage of that compared to
how we do it now well that was actually
for a sensor
um there is a sensor called the uh ma701
ma704 and it's a position sensor
that uses uh it's a magnetic position
sensor so it's just like an encoder
but a very high resolution one and
unlike an encoder it can go up to about
60 000 rpm or something ridiculously
so it's um you could essentially make a
sense
it was for ground vehicles
they get a nice uh end of shaft sensor
that can go on to in-runner motors and
give me
zero to whatever rpm and ice control
i think um it was one of those ideas
that uh
this sort of fell to the wayside like so
many
yeah but that was one of the reasons for
wanting a 32-bit controller
um also the uh there's there's more
things you can do with the timers the
resolution of the timers
especially in the 8-bit processors once
you get if you can see it in the detail
resolution as you get higher too it's
they're really pushing the limits of
what they can do with them and it's
uh and i'm working on some
field-oriented control
and i have been from there's esc's and
that's all 32-bit based because you
really need
uh or heavy math functions um
and so it's uh i think for me that
you know i i program in c and i don't uh
you know i could rather not try to
learn assembly and go through all the
bits and bytes i just want to
work on the higher logic given the
choice between
decoding bl helis's assembly and
just writing it all from scratch i can
totally understand why you wrote it all
from scratch
that's actually the rational decision
now that i understand it
yeah and i mean to get it spinning was
actually really i
i thought i was gonna do amazing it's
the first week
i had this motor spinning i was like
this is no problem at all
and then d shot holy crap and then
bi-directional d-shot and the amount of
coding that you have to go through that
was just
yeah but i mean i wanted to keep all the
code um
original and i wanted to try to even if
it's not the best
way to do it i mean it's it's all open
source and it's all
uh fairly legible so you know somebody
can maybe read my code and
and write it out in assembly or put it
in you know do it better i'm sure
people are doing it better already but
it sounds like there's a potential here
for the am 32 project to be an
open source alternative to blheli32
for because other other people who maybe
want like there are people right now
like um joe lucid and jesus c or jazz
maverick
uh who are extending vl heli s
far past what anyone thought was
possible but like you said they're
hitting the limits of what that hardware
is even capable of
and they can't really where are they
going to go from there
and now it sounds like maybe am32 is a
place to
have a code base that runs on more
sophisticated
hardware i don't know you know it works
and i mean uh
i know joe is or thorstein is his name
i bet it better yes i'm not sure but
thirsty
i think is his name yeah he took my code
he could do some amazing stuff with it
and
probably i mean it's it's a lot easier
to understand and had to
uh but uh everybody seems to want to do
their own thing
you know and he sees online with us at
the
this sort of started off in the uh in
the chat
spaces of the beta fight flight
open esc firmware group where we sort of
uh i mean i had a little bit of working
firmware that wasn't very well written a
few years ago
never had any sort of commercial intent
to
make it work on other hardware past my
own
and uh i mean and
uh joe lucid was always there working on
his own
you know working just flogging the bb2
to death i mean
he just tried to get every last little
bit of performance out of it as you can
and we were just saying like why don't
you
why don't you help us with this why
don't you use this and help us
it's a process it works it flies it
works great
but it just you know he liked to do his
own thing and
and then jazz maverick was on there too
but he
didn't listen to anybody um yeah i've
heard that
so uh yeah i mean so
it just became something that i picked
away at until eventually reached a point
where it sort of was a tipping point
where
i think it was the configurator i think
once i got um
the pass-through working with theo helix
so
you no longer have to take your your
esc's out of your quadcopter and solder
onto them and
so now you can just plug in a usb
controller or usb
port in the way you go that was really
the point where
people started using it and it's uh well
let me ask you so right now there are no
commercially available esc's
that come with your firmware on him is
that right
so how do people if they want to try
this how do they
because you sent me some esc's that you
had already flashed if somebody wants to
try this what do they need to do
well you know it's really this
my design for it was for hobbyists to
put on their own
hardware right so it's uh that's really
who i
i support people who make their own
hardware
i do have a set of firmware instructions
and flashing instructions to re
remove bl heli from an esc and put am 32
on but i don't know if i would do that
i mean it's like well listen to
somebody's perfectly good working
engine out of something and replacing
with something else you say that but the
same thing that motivated you to do this
project in the first place
is going to motivate somebody else to
try out am32
yeah does it require a special
programming adapter or is it just done
through usb at the first one it would
require an st link yeah and it's because
the
the bootloader that for bl heli32 is
locked and the pscs are
read out protected and right protected
you have to unlock
some option bits through an st link to
even make the
chip writable and so that's
that's the unfortunate thing and then
once you've done that
you can upload uh a bootloader that i
have
um that is on my
repo on github and then from there
everything is done with just through
pass through and bl heli suite
a ble configurator or am32 configurator
they both work
very well got you now i'm looking on
amazon and i'm just seeing st link
programmers for like 10 bucks is that
what you're
this and do they have to solder it onto
pads or does it how does it connect to
the
to this chip yeah pretty much all of
them have
every four and one has those little pads
on it
um i see and you just have to uh what i
made is a little set of like
they're almost like little pins so just
two little
needles and i just sort of stab them
onto the
pads on the board close together and
then while i'm holding them there i
i press the buttons to gotcha so it's
it's kind of a
you know but there are some uh for
some commercial esc's coming out i
suppose
i i've been paid some royalties for them
so
yeah so i don't care if they come out
now but
you know they're they're they're gonna
be out there i think and the diets own
uh so that's why they've got we've got
three diaton targets that are on
uh that are actually properly named
targets and they have proper
dead times matched for their hardware
and
those ones are because they gave us a
little bit of money and they
they have so many controllers that they
want to put out with this on it
and they would rather actually they said
they wanted to do something instead of
doing it for free
they'd rather pay us a little bit i hope
that they're compensating you fairly for
the amount of benefit that they're
getting
in terms of not having to pay however
much the royalty is for billy 32
yeah well and that's that's the tricky
thing i mean it's uh
it's nice that i'm getting anything at
all
because it is open source and they can
just
oh that's true and release it
um and that's what we're it's where it's
hard to
keep tabs on that really who's going to
use it what they're going to use it for
how many people are going to use it um
and really if we start getting a lot of
support requests
yeah then we'll say look who sold you
the se who made it
go to them ask well you're going to end
up in the exact same position that
that stefan did when they shifted from
blle as to bla32 i mean
they started charging money for bloody
30. that i was so
impressed and i'm not that i'm not
impressed now but
when blheli s was out i would see people
almost literally begging stefan to take
they're like please will you take a
donation can i send you can i contribute
and they said no they just refused all
donations from people they just wanted
to make this
and only when the support requests got
to the point where they were like we
can't do this anymore did they switch
to billy 32 which was a licensed model
and they were like well i guess if this
is our job we may as well get paid so
here's your github repo
and am 32 multi-rotor esc firmware in
the right-hand side here
okay got it and then under release
release there for now and then i'm going
to
uh plug in usb
controller plug in the battery
right then connector exe it's at the
very bottom there
ah great okay
and then you should be able to find your
serial port bottom left
will it connect automatically no just
hit connect okay
hit connect there you go okay
and now what and now you should be able
to click on a motor
one at a time or all four at once click
it once one there okay
connecting esc number one there you go
huh
so that means i just read all these the
settings from that esc
i'm looking at these options um the
options look pretty standard reverse
rotation
now variable pwm that's something that
blheli32
has in their nightlys but have not
released yet hang on let me take let me
make you full screen again
yeah he actually gave me credit on his
uh and his
his forum there about about coming up
with that one
but variable pwm it's pretty cool it's
uh it solves a lot of problems
um and i mean the the
i i do it a little differently than he
does it right now too
and i think that my option well
i'll explain it a bit first but
the uh first of all the problem
with a fixed pwm rate and a motor
spinning is once you get to
motor frequencies uh commutation
frequencies that are approaching the
harmonics
of the pwm rate the motor actually wants
to sort of stick to those frequencies
and you see
bumps in rpm and you see that the rpm
will sort of stick to those commutation
rates
so variable pwm frequency first of all
always changes the pwm frequency based
on the rotation speed so
the that is just
hold on hold on you just blew my mind a
tiny bit
it's pretty cool that is so i've always
thought about it variable pwm
from the perspective of the torque that
that at higher frequencies
you have less torque and so when i
thought about variable pwm
i thought about low pwm frequency
at low rpm high pwn frequency at high
rpm that's kind of a
small side effect benefit of it too
you just blew my mind you're
specifically avoiding
the harmonics of the motor rpm and
that's insane
that's where mine starts so right before
mine stays at 24 kilohertz
until the motor is at around 11
and a half kilohertz commutation speed
at that point i start stepping up the
pwm frequency proportionally
with the speed of the motor so it never
reaches
that point and that works for ninety
percent of the motors
in their range that you don't see any
rpm discrepancies and you don't see any
stiction
and it makes it so smooth you get this
nice very smooth feeling from start to
finish
and it starts off at 24 kilohertz and
ends up at 48 kilohertz
if your motor goes faster than a certain
you will find a
a sticking point but generally when
you're when you're at full throttle
you're not you don't care so much it's
it's
the mid throttles right notice right
like
yes at low rpm
you're concerned mostly about torque
because you
you don't have you need to stabilize
yourself at low rpm
and at mid rpm you're very concerned
about those harmonics
because during cruise you'll just get
these little jitters and shutters
right but at high rpm you have plenty of
torque because the motor is just going
hog wild yeah and smoothness i mean
you're just at such high rpm
that you're usually not concerned so
much about smoothness when you're at
full throttle
yeah exactly and it doesn't really seem
to i mean
they the the torque difference i i don't
know i'm not gonna
i'm talking on my ass so i don't know
anything about it so
um but when it comes to pwm frequency
it really does um like
as you get higher in pwm frequency you
do lose a little bit of torque in the
high end
i mean it's uh your dead time gets
longer proportionally
um as a proportion of time in total so
you lose a little bit of your driving
power you lose a little bit of your
braking power
um but you do avoid those pwm harmonics
and you make the
um even just staying at a higher fixed
pwm frequency you make the pw harmonics
lesser but doing a variable frequency
that stays with
the pwm frequency and just keeps it
fairly out of range
it does have a nice effect and you can
see it when you do sort of do a
zero to full rpm curve and it just it's
a dead straight line all the way up
which is interesting pretty cool that's
really fascinating i'm um that's that's
interesting and i'll be interesting to
compare that to how
so how does ble32 doing it do you know
well
so i think he's going to do it like i do
once he okay
once he sees the advantage he just
picked a 0 to 100 and starts off at 24
and at full throttle is at 48 kilohertz
or
96 kilohertz uh it's not based on
commutation frequency like minus so it's
gotcha
so i think the difference is the pl
heli1 is based on throttle mines based
on the speed of the mode
because i saw that you have motor poles
in the configurator and i was like well
why
the reason you need motor poles is
because you want to know the motor rpm
the actual rpm
which betaflight uses that for the rpm
filter but i couldn't figure out why the
esc needed that
but now i see your vl heli option that
you've probably
seen which is low rpm throttle protect
that's in the configurator um and what
is low rpm
for beta for bl heli i mean it's uh
it's a fixed number um and so that's the
thing and that's why there's some
problem with people who run big motors
with it because
you either have to turn it off and on
it's a fixed
fixed amount there's not a so my our i
have the same thing you have to
restrict throttle at very low rpms
otherwise
you'll just blow motors left right so
mine is based
on the actual rpm on the motor poles and
the kv
rather than a fixed number so it's not
something that below a certain rpm
it's restricted it depends on the mode
the flip side of this is that anybody
using this
feature is going to have to go into the
bl heli or into the configurator and put
their motor poles in the esc
which yeah it would be super cool if
there was a d-shot command that could
communicate that information
because people are not going to be able
not going to be thinking to do that
it would be yeah no and i i i set my
default to
the same rpm as the l heli one
so it's um if you don't select anything
you don't ever go into the configurator
it'll work just like you expect
you'll have to turn the option off if
you're going to use it with like
6000 kv motors i was going to say i mean
you go up to 48k but if you're if you're
going to use this on like a
let's say you've got a 25 4 000
i'm just thinking the highest kv motor i
can like a mobile six
yeah a little uh 24 000 kv
1s like is there a point where the rpm
gets high enough that you have to go
above 48k or do you just
say screw it we're not going to worry
about it because the high throttle rpm
yeah in terms of pwm frequency um
we see right now i don't really most of
my firmware is for pretty generic
hardware
and i don't think most of it can support
96 kilohertz so once we start
supporting more specific wear then we
will start pushing pwm frequency up on
those ones but
right now i think that it's uh 48
kilohertz is really
it does pretty well for for the most
part and it's uh
even for little motors it's pretty good
yeah
you can sort of make up for the
efficiency
difference by just increasing the
bedtime well that's what i was going to
say the
other the other argument for 48k er
is that especially on small quads like
tiny whoops
you get significant increase in flight
time and people have suggested that's
related to the dead time
although i don't know the details but it
sounds like what you're saying is you
could just manipulate the dead time
and leave the pwm alone and still reap
those advantages
i i have a feeling you can and i've done
a you know i haven't really done too
many tests on little motors
but uh i mean if you reduce the braking
cycle
considerably that uh i mean it'll make a
big difference for little motors
i mean it the there is some loss in the
motors
uh and a higher pwm frequency does
reduce the inductive loss of the motor
because as those tiny little motors are
just like a dent short of wires
well too low of pwm frequency and you
just see this massive torque ripple
the i think that the one of the biggest
differences and one of the things that
happens with our drivers is that
as we go up in pwm frequency we get uh
like disproportionately longer dead time
because we're taking
um we're taking our dead time out of the
breaking time only
do so we're doubling our dead time each
time we double our pwm frequency
if we keep our driving time the same so
if we still go from zero to a hundred
when it comes to our on time
when we double the pwm frequency each
time the only thing we can be doing is
doubling our dead time because
we still have to go from zero to 100 you
know on time
we've talked about this at quite a bit
too and we uh we've never really been
able to come up with any conclusive
answers yet because a lot of us just
haven't done the tests and we uh i
really should
i mean yeah but
i think that with a bl heli
uh esc you can probably test it out
because i think you can change the dead
time
i think there's adjustable braking which
is an option so you can probably just
set it to 48 kilohertz and reduce the
braking
and see if that gives you more flight
time and i think that it probably will
i think that it's uh you'll see you'll
probably see about the same difference
in
flight time um
i'm just talking on my ass again yeah
well that's what it all started
you start with talking at your ass then
you do some tests and you find out if
you were right but
that's right that's called we call that
a hypothesis right
yeah it's talking about your ass yeah
when you when you say things you end up
saying a lot of things wrong and i i say
a lot of things in forums and they have
to go back
by what i say but that's how i learn a
lot of the things too
yes i i say it and then i research it
myself after i say it and like
i shouldn't have said that
that's really silly but yeah well yeah
i'm gonna uh now that we've got the
latest firmware and the updated settings
on this i'm gonna go give it another try
and uh you know it's uh and just uh
have fun with it and if people ask you a
question about it you know just tell
them not to be scared about it
we're supporting it you know it's uh i'm
gonna keep on working on it forever and
i'm not gonna stop until it's
i mean this this works for uh
flying you know quadcopters and
and ground vehicles it does uh brushed
motors as well
it also works for induction motors so i
mean you could use this for just about
anything and it's what my intention is
is you have one firmware that can
control
any motor out there and uh i'm i'm
hopefully hopefully lots of people come
and
join the project yeah
it's especially exciting i think because
i i know there are going to be people
out there
who are interested in an open source
uh esc firmware that runs on modern
hardware
as opposed to trying to shoehorn stuff
into bl heli s i'm sure those
probably not a lot of people because how
many people are coding esc's but
i'm sure that you're going to see some
traction especially once the diatone
hardware
becomes available and people no longer
have to use the st link
programmer although the kind of person
who's writing esc firmware isn't scared
of an st link programmer to be honest
that's the thing yeah so i mean it's uh
most of my
my user base i probably got like 25
people
use it right now they're the handful of
people i sent off yes
these two but most of them are people
making their own
hardware and there is absolutely no
option apart from this when it comes to
an open source
32. if you want to make your own
hardware and a new microcontroller
this is it i mean so that's really um
so it has to exist for that reason
anyway okay
well do you know when diaton is going to
be releasing the csc
i don't know i mean the the latest
version is uh
it's stable we haven't uh we haven't
blown up a motor in a very long time
which is good and uh good
seems to be seems to be flying quite
nicely so
really i i do it for the fun of it so
i'm trying not to get too
involved into in the business part of
things but
you know well i'm gonna uh i'll ping
them and see what their plans are
because i'm sure there will be people
who are interested yeah
no there's a company called neutron em
neutron rc which is going to be
releasing some new hardware soon which
is a brand new sort of startup that i'm
working with
okay and they will have some hardware
that
we've we've sort of designed the
hardware and software from the ground up
so the speed controller is based on the
g
the g071 mcu
which are is the same as kiss is using
for their new fetech
four and one esc um a really nice little
mcu it's a big step up over the uh
the previous generation fo51s and we're
using the g
uh g four three ones g four four seven
fours for the flight controller so we're
moving from the f
series to the g series and uh there
seems to be some
big advantages to them so we're focusing
our new development anyway on
on the g series and their latest series
of
sd yeah everybody seems to be going to
the h7 but other people have pointed out
that the h7
has like it has less memory than the and
even the f7
um it may not be like the best choice to
go to
yeah it's uh i don't know i've got this
little like this uh
this one's a g474 on this flight
controller here
and that one is right now it seems to
run faster than the f4s at a much
lower um much lower power consumption
um and it's uh i think those are just
about the best
flight controller processors that i've
seen all kinds of inputs and outputs
they're running 170 megahertz too which
is quite quite good math
acceleration um and i mean it's it's the
logical
successor to the f series so it's
um this one runs at 60
66 or 666 kilohertz gyro frequency or
333 because it uses a
new gyro2 or something i don't know
uh it's running really stable and i've
been pretty impressed with it so far
well i think that we're going to see
more of those in the market too
some new stuff is going to be coming out
yeah it sounds like it sounds like you
that you
you got your really your finger on the
pulse of the market at least what's
coming
here's some cool little ones so we're
going to see some really small little
foreign ones
there's a this is this is it for that
speed control there's actually no
mosfets on the back
each of these devices there's three of
them on the front is
a driver and dual mosfet
wow so that saves the place of three
components each which is you know the
driver is normally the uh four by four
size
chip on its own and then the mosfets
would be six of those after the drivers
so it's
combines it down to three four by four
millimeter chips which is pretty cool
yeah what's the current capacity of that
what's the current capacity of it not
very much oh i was gonna say okay
yeah i think that's meant for more like
the i and
um there's a bit of uh
when the boards were sent to me the
company that sent them out
they said these things are rated for 30
amps to 60 amps because that's what it
says in the data sheet
and you know it's you know mosfets how
they say you know up to 160 amps or 100
and you know 400 amps package limited
so they thought that they were you know
making some 60 amp
speed controller with it but they they
do well for like the
you know a small whoop size board which
would be the kind of thing that because
they go onto a 20 by 20 yeah
we're playing with new toys that's right
it's all just for playing with toys
isn't it
i think that's what i do you say that
that's
that's what it ought to be right yeah we
can't get to
you know it's all right pete i'm gonna
let you go
thank you so much uh for sending this
stuff to me um
and uh we can talk again um
do you see this baby isn't he cute
hit the subscribe button join my patreon
use my affiliate links or just keep
watching videos
that's better than nothing
subscribe to my daddy